you do any mushrooms on tour with him
nah I tried it though you tried some
shrooms yeah for the first time and I I
look I tried it before right yeah
but like
I ain't feel nothing I'm like you know
you didn't eat enough some [ __ ]
right yeah I know you big on mushrooms
of course yeah yeah I got some gummies
for you for real yeah yeah but no I I
tried this [ __ ] or whatever
because I was hearing so much positive
[ __ ] about it yeah last time we talked
you hadn't tried them yet yeah like I
was hearing oh it opens your mind I'm
thinking I'm gonna eat this [ __ ]
and make the hardest song ever and [ __ ]
right so I was in the studio and I hate
that [ __ ] and it was like
it was I ain't feel nothing and then
when I got in the car to like dip
and then just the colors started getting
hella vibrant and yep all a bunch of
[ __ ] I was just smiling for no reason
and [ __ ] so
and then when you go to go to sleep you
close your eyes and you start thinking
like yeah way way deeper yeah like [ __ ]
yeah I was thinking deep as [ __ ] I'm
like this is crazy yeah but now I ain't
really I ain't get to that moment I
ain't get to the mode that you got on
you've been on the little god mode you
just gotta eat a whole bag
she ain't I don't want like at home you
know or like in a controlled environment
not don't do it on tour yeah do you you
tried it on tour
or you were like it was this yeah I
tried it on tour but it didn't work oh I
see I see it yes I was like I ain't
gonna [ __ ] with it no more it was kind
of nice you know what happened though
bro what I went to Amsterdam right and I
did like a whole European Festival tour
went to Amsterdam
and they will stay like you know they
open with this [ __ ] yeah so they got a
mushroom store
so you go in there they got they had
like these mushroom truffles or whatever
right so I'm like [ __ ] I'm from the
bodies [ __ ] I'm in Amsterdam
you know [ __ ] don't smoke [ __ ] Gonna
Pop a little mushroom whatever the [ __ ]
right so I grab it
and then I um I go to eat it
and like probably like an hour later bro
I got the sickest I've ever been like I
threw up all over h m and everything you
threw up in an h m threw up in h m how
did this not end up on TMZ
I don't know they just didn't recognize
you you do hey you threw up in hm in La
ddg pukes at h m which is [ __ ] all
over academics and [ __ ] that's what I'm
saying but it was some low-key [ __ ] it
was just that's dope third floor agent
got the throwing up one of the employees
knew who I was so they grabbed me a
little bag to throw up in and [ __ ] wow
and then I left there did you have to
buy new clothes at h m because you puked
on your other one I ain't throw up on
myself I threw up on they [ __ ] sick Pew
control bro yeah so then uh you have to
buy the stuff you puked on no no no no
the guy who knew it was you just he
bought it for himself and it's probably
on eBay right now yeah I left DG Pew
confused plain black h m shirt 89.99 on
eBay
probably more than that [ __ ] maybe